got to defend my buddy charlie kirk for
a moment charlie kirk as he often does
was trending on twitter
he got in trouble charlie is always
getting himself in trouble and medium
matters and jason campbell who i refer
to as my personal publicist he is one of
the people who were at media matters
they work they just watch all of our
shows all day and they try to get us
fired and they haven't they've gotten
close sometimes but they have not
succeeded in doing that so he was going
after charlie and he pulled this clip
from charlie said this is shocking this
is insane
he says quote charlie kirk warns that
democrats want you
living in sexual anarchy here's what
charlie said you think we're still
living in the 1980s where the democrats
actually want
what's best for america
the democrats want to destroy the
country we know this
this is not new stuff
it's not profound thinking
they want to see america completely
obliterated the constitution shredded
and remade in their own
san francisco brooklyn
malibu manhattan image
where there is no cultural identity
where you live in sexual anarchy
for private property is a thing of the
past and the ruling class controls
everything
we know this crazy that charlie can you
believe charlie said that's insane i
totally disagree but what
but what did he get wrong exactly what
what part of what he just said
was wrong
i think a conservative will listen to
that and say no that's obviously just
common sense but what's weird here is
that
i think even a liberal even some left
winger like the people at media matters
if they're being honest which they
usually are not but if they're being
honest at least with themselves
i think they would agree with what
charlie said too
what is sexual anarchy
it seems to me that the the dominant
view of sexual morality since the 1960s
at least
is
if it feels good do it
if you want to do something sexually if
you want to have pre-marital sex if you
want to hook up if you want to do
whatever you want to do
if if you want to do it you should do it
and there's only one little caveat here
which is that everything's got to be
consensual so if things are not
consensual then eventually you get some
me too problems and things they're not
going to go that far as to defend rape
but anything short of non-consensual sex
it seems to me the left defends
right that well what is sexual anarchy
sexual anarchy right anarchy is the
system where there's no formal
government you don't really have to
follow any any rules beyond the defense
of one's own
radical individual autonomy and consent
and then you apply this in the realm of
sex it seems like charlie is using a
very precise term to describe exactly
what the left wants but the left knows
that that's insane at some
deep deep down level i think the left
knows that that is insane to say that
sexually or in any other aspect of life
you can do absolutely whatever you want
and there are no rules and no moral
order whatsoever so they don't want to
admit that but that is what they're
saying that is what they're defending
and charlie kirk was absolutely 100
correct i am so glad
it makes me feel very good to know that
you liked that clip
and that's cool you can leave a little
comment click the like subscribe that's
great but you can get the whole show
okay the entire michael knowles show
podcast you can get it for free right
here at youtube or if you want the audio
experience without any of the censorship
that occasionally accompanies this uh
wonderful platform head on over apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
myspace xanga
aol instant messenger go subscribe to
the michael knowles show podcast see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you